as far back as as nineteen as the
mechanical bride which was 1952 McLuhan
was talking about what he called
electronic feudalism and said the world
will fragment and it seemed completely
unlikely because the United Nations was
on the rise these vast power blocks were
squared off but I think it's clearly
happening I think that federal Europe is
a dream it will never happen it's dead
the people reject it it's only in the
glass ministries in Brussels that the
heart beats fast for European federalism
now it's finished
Russia is falling apart Russia will
become what the Soviet Union was 15
separate warring factions 32 out of 36
Northern California counties voted to
separate from Southern California Canada
is falling apart and strangely enough
meanwhile at the top in the world of
George Bush and John Major's there's a
feverish enthusiasm for unity for great
trade bloc's and wide flung negotiation
this is clearly a last-ditch effort to
keep this globalism together and you
know Yugoslavia is a bad example
obviously but it was the inheritor of
great power rivalry I think that
Czechoslovakia that dissolution is the
one to watch because here people simply
want to rule their own turf and after
all why shouldn't they like one of the
most suspect notions running around is
free trade free trade is a notion that
people right-thinking people of decent
upbringing are expected to stand up and
salute what free trade means is the
right to sell crap everywhere
the right to deal coca-cola in
Afghanistan that's what free trade is
the right to sell Volvo's in
Turkmenistan it's a bad idea free trade
we don't want to make trade easier we
want to make the manufacture of objects
an excruciatingly ly expensive process
and the moving them from one market to
another damn near impossible because
what we want is the dematerialization of
culture what free trade means is turning
the entire world into a marketplace for
high-tech pre obsolescent durable goods
and yet you know nobody points this out
at all people that and what's going on
in the American economy is that over the
past twelve years under the aegis of the
crypto-fascist Republic rats an enormous
transfer of wealth has gone on to the
top 3% in in 1986 Americans had more
than a billion dollars in 1992 over 80
Americans have more than a billion
dollars meanwhile most Americans have
gotten considerably poorer because the
money which was not transferred to the
super-rich was transferred to the third
world the great leveling which the left
always called for has in fact taken
place in part and that's why you have
less money because you when the leveling
took place did you think it was going to
kick back into your pocketbook you
haven't visited Bangladesh recently so a
whole bunch of manipulations have gone
on which tend to I think support the
idea that nations are being looted and
dissolved by ethnic factionalism
and corporate hegemony and that in the
future these are the two things that
will exist
and you know people will
it's a Japanese model basically I mean
in Japan your corporation is your
identity if you're really embedded in
the culture and the nation-state
I'm not sure whether this is a bad thing
or a good thing I mean the nation-state
has become a fascist tool all
nation-states what these companies stand
for is unbridled gangsterism but on the
other hand that's what political
revolution has often meant in the past
so it's a it's a complicated situation
the world is futile izing fractioning
into interest blocks at the same time
that technologically mentioned mtv
technologically it's being met into a
single psychology
[Music]
you
[Music]